All right, folks, welcome back.
This is episode number eight, Applying Institutional Order Flow to Forex Markets.
Taking a look at trading view, and I promise this is going to be a really short one tonight.
Let's go to Euro.
And whenever I'm looking at data from trading view, this is the
data feed I use for Forex pairs only. Forex.com, I don't want to use Oando, definitely not them.
All right, so we have the daily chart up for Euro, Yen.
Just so you know, I hate Yen pairs, I can't stand them, but for the sake of completeness,
this is how you would look for these types of patterns in Forex.
Now, I have lots of feedback in the comments section that you don't get to see,
but it's really just for me. I get a lot of requests whether or not this is
appropriate to be using for higher time frame charts, and I think daily charts are
what everybody classifies as a higher time frame chart.
So I want you to take a look at this chart before I do any mock-up on it.
Pause the video if you're not ready.
Still don't pause it, do you? All right, take a look at the
relative equal lows over here. See that? It's going to go quick and dirty tonight.
Right and dirty. All right, so we have relative equal lows marked out over here.
The market has traded down through and created a run higher.
Now, here is why I do not like the Yen pairs. Okay, I get questioned all the time. Why don't
you like Yen pairs? I see they move around nice, they do this, they do that. They tend to have like
a double return to a specific level I like to see, and you're going to see it right here.
Okay, swing high. The market rallies through that. There's no fair value out there.
It drops back down in, then it runs again, taking out this swing high. So we have two
points of market structure that have moved to the upside and over its prices traded above it.
Now, this leg here, you want to go back through that and see is there a fair value gap? Well,
we have one and two. Market trades down into it here,
sends it higher. What's above here? Buy side liquidity. This old high back here could be a
draw on liquidity as well. So there's going to be buy stops. Whether it trades there or not,
it's irrelevant. Okay, it's likely to draw to it. Just like, you know, playing horseshoes.
You ever play the game horseshoes? Not every single time you throw a horseshoe,
is it going to go on that post. But it's still fun to play, right? So you're aiming at that post,
whether you hit that post or not, and this would be the post in the game. Playing horseshoes,
you're just aiming for it. Now, obviously, we started trading a new day here, but this candle,
which was the 10th of February, 2022, this daily candle, we could trust that this was likely to go
higher because we went up, we've consolidated, and then start another run into this high here.
Again, whether it trades through it or not, it's irrelevant. Okay, because even a failure swing
to get above old highs, if there's enough range from being right here at the open to reaching up
to here, that's enough to take a stab at it and to see if you're going to get any kind of yield.
So that's an example of it occurring on a daily chart, but I want to go into this very day right
there, okay, the 10th. So we're going to drop down into a 15-minute time frame.
All right, here's the 15-minute time frame, and we're going to mark up our chart.
Midnight New York time, market rallies in here.
And then we go into the New York session right here. So we're going to go into this
price structure and figure it out, the run that occurred in here. So I'm going to
put a rectangle in this area so that way we know what we're looking at relative to this 15-minute time frame.
You guys ask why I do PowerPoint slides, this is the reason why.
It makes it a lot easier to go right to what I'm looking for. All right, we're going to drop down
to a five-minute chart. Okay, and if you take a look at
that,
seven o'clock in the morning, 10 o'clock in the morning, that's your New York
ICT kills in. Okay, that's the time of day that New York Session trades form.
I have more information in that regard for time of day for Forex in this channel. There's just
lots of videos, lots of topics and things you can explore. I don't want to beat it to death
because I've already done it in other places, but just know that seven o'clock in the morning
to 10 o'clock in the morning, New York time, again, on TradingView, you need to have it
toggled to that. Everything else, it'll be wrong. All right, so here is the time of day that the
forming of a New York setup forms. All right, so we have the market trading down,
takes out a swing low, trades down below that, and then punches higher, right above the swing high.
Inside this price lag right here, is there a fair value gap?
We're going to start breaking it down top down from five minutes.
Top down. We're going to break it down from the five minute down to the one minute chart.
So from this low, up to this high,
right in there. That's where we're going to study on each new time frame. So we'll go down to three
minutes. Okay, so in this price lag here, do we take out a swing low? Yes, we trade down below
swing low. Does it take out a swing high here? Yes, it does. So now we have a valid condition
to see if there's a trade. Go back through this price lag. Is there a fair value gap?
Right in here, and this one here. So remember what I was teaching you. It could stab down there.
Just be mindful of that, but try to get your entry in on that one there.
And this we have here trades down to it there. Now the question is going to be is how far
will it trade to? Because we're not looking at anything over here,
like it's a middle of the range type idea. So for expansion type moves,
practical lesson tonight, where if we don't have a range to trade inside of,
how do we anticipate how far I can trade up or trade down? In this case, we're looking for
a long. Where would our targets be? Because the old high is over here. Now I'm sure if we
went to a hard time frame, keep looking to the left, we'll find something. But a real easy way
is to take your price lag over here. See this swing low right prior to this run up.
Then we consolidated, drop down, create a discount, and then created our retracement rally
and start to run up into these highs. How can we know? Well, I like to take a fib,
and anchor it to a previous swing. Okay, so from this low that is high,
after we lead this consolidation to start to trade higher,
standard deviation, negative one, and I got a lot of questions. What's my setup for my fib? I
actually show that on the OTE primer video, so you're welcome to take a look at that on
the YouTube channel as well. 133.153 and high is 133.153, so right to the point that you'd be
looking for. And then we've seen it recede from that. Okay, so obviously when I show an example
like this, it makes me want to trade me in. But I hate this pair. I can't stand. There's other
markets that can scratch my itch for Forex, but this one is not one I like to trade. But I wanted
to come out tonight and kind of give you a quick view of what you could do with these
markets using the model. Okay, there is a approach that you can use with the London session,
okay, and London would be marking up your vertical lines relative to New York local time,
two o'clock in the morning to five a.m., so you'd have your bracket. So your operating hours would
be hunting the setup for New York between seven o'clock in the morning and ten o'clock
local New York time. For London session trades, you would look for setups that would
provide you a way to trade a fair value gap between two o'clock in the morning and five
o'clock in the morning. Okay, and that's as easy as I can make it for you. It's simple,
and any additional information you would want to have, I have absolutely covered it
in other videos in this YouTube channel. Okay, so it's predominantly a Forex channel,
and it's only been recently with the 2022 mentorship I'm talking and teaching about
the stock indices. So I got a lot of requests for Forex, so here you go. It's simply applying
what you've been trained with the futures indices, but just applying it to the Forex market,
but applying it to the time of day relative to New York or London. And yes, you can take trades
in Asia. Yes, you can take trades in London Close, but I'd prefer to have you just trade on
these two time frames here, or time of day rather, being New York open, which is what's being shown
here, seven o'clock in the morning to ten o'clock in the morning, New York local time. Again, always,
I can't say it enough because if you don't do this and you just have it set to your local time,
it won't work. But it's New York local time on TradingView, seven o'clock to ten o'clock. This
is the time when you're hunting the setup. Okay, so in summary, we can anticipate this market going
higher. Why? Because the Euro dollar is going higher. You can also check it by going to, let's
go to the daily chart first, and go to 6E, which is Euro futures, and let us use the front month
continuous. Okay, you can see how Euro, where has it been going? So has it been going lower or higher?
Clearly going higher. What has the yen been doing?
So when you look at Forex pairs, you want to look for that relationship between the instruments that
make up your pair. So Euro yen, Euro is strong, yen is weak. So what would that mean for Euro yen?
It would mean that if your bias is bullish, and you have this underpinning
between Euro and yen, it's going to make this pair go higher. It's a real simple way of looking at
how to determine these exotic crosses. Okay, and how to frame the logic behind whether it should
go higher or lower. In the applied time of day, wait for the pattern I'm teaching you, and you
won't need to do anything else. You don't need to buy a subscription to anybody's services. You
don't need to learn anything else. You don't have to buy any courses. It's all right here for free,
and it works. Until I talk to you next week, enjoy your weekend, and be safe.